تقدم اكثر من 600 محام من مختلف القارات
بدعوه لمحكمه الجنايات الدوليه ضد قاده
اسرائيل بخصوص الجرائم المرتكبه على
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله وقال المحامي
الفرنسي جليز ديفرز في مؤتمر صحفي عقده
المحامون عقب تقديم الدعوه ان هناك كثيرا
من الادله على استهداف اسرائيل للمدنيين
في
غزه هناك ممارسات عسكريه تستهدف تحديدا
المدنيين
الفلسطينيين اكثر من
25000 كذلك يتم استهداف منشات الخدمات
كالمياه وغيرها وهناك تدمير لجميع مقومات
الحياه هذا وتستعد محكمه العدل الدوليه
لاصدار قرارها يوم غد الجمعه بشان احتمال
فرض اجراءات طارئه على اسرائيل عقب
اتهامات من جنوب افريقيا بان العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في غزه تمثل اباده
جماعيه بقياده الدوله وقالت المحكمه في
بيان ان اللجنه المؤلفه من 17 قاضيا ستصدر
قرارها الساعه الان ع ظهرا بتوقيت جرينتش
من يوم الجمعه ولن تتناول المحكمه المساله
الرئيسيه المتعلقه بارتكاب اسرائيل اباده
جماعيه لكنها ستبحث في امكانيه اتخاذ
اجراءات طارئه لمنع تفاقم النزاع حتى تنظر
المحكمه في القضيه باكملها وهو ما قد
يستغرق سنوات
عده يعقد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو اليوم اجتماعا تشاوريا لبحث
سيناريوهات القرار المرتقب غدا الجمعه عن
محكمه العدل الدوليه بشان الدعوه التي
رفعتها جنوب افريقيا واتهمت فيها اسرائيل
بارتكاب جرائم اباده في غزه ونقلت وسائل
اعلام اسرائيليه ان اسرائيل تعد
سيناريوهات مختلفه في ردودها المتوقعه كما
تعول على استخدام الولايات المتحده لحق
النقض الفيتو في حال وصول قرار المحكمه
الى مجلس
الامن